hey everyone hey welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
we don't do this episode often you know
it's a kind of not a regular thing we've
got a schedule but you know we're going
slowly through Watchmen Alan Moore and
Dave Gibbons Watchmen primarily going
issue by issue but it's wonderful what's
happened is when we've done the show
a Sikh Wars came out on DC so inevitably
we have to review it with some smirk
with some mirth you know with some
honesty but but yet Doomsday Clock is of
course what I'm talking about
by Geoff Johns and it is never myself I
am as ever welcomed by a good friend my
co-host death as a good man ground
control to Major Tom come on Tom how are
you doing yeah I'm good it's been a bit
of a bit of a crazy month for me a last
month last time we were recording I
actually got a phone call and like my
phone was gone crazy off my grandma and
we'll call her Nana she yeah she rang to
tell me that my granddad had went in the
hospital many passed away the the week
after and then we've just got his his
funeral out the way and like I know it's
a sad way to start the show honestly
like you had had a really really
peaceful death and it was really nice
and it his funeral was great and he was
a bit of a comedian right the funeral
was a bit like the comedian's because
what all stood around and thought about
the time they shot that pregnant
Vietnamese woman [ __ ] and her love Tom
but yeah so just want to dedicate this
this episode to William Bruce Billy
Brewster called him yet but just being a
bit of a crazy month and which is why
we're a bit late on the episode because
for one I've got a lot of stuff going on
I don't know about you Tom mm-hmm but
had a lot of stuff going on and I don't
really like the comic so I'm not I'm not
exactly late look Nanna
I know I meant it becoming the funeral a
day but Doomsday Clock threes just come
out so [ __ ] years you know I mean I
should say you know it's not who and
we you know we've gone back was on The
Killing Joke in between and check out
our earlier editions of Doomsday Clock
as well we've been following the story
we're everyone else death I don't have
you heard quite controversially the
comic is going by monthly so now it's
every two months rather than everyone
which means doomsday couple finish july
2019 it is [ __ ] controversial may not
be asked so long it Ben Stein and
himself
tachyons yeah well it must be confident
that the stories like honest yeah I
really don't like when stories go by
monthly yeah Batman the Batman run
recently did it at the start of rebirth
and I think it's massively affected like
the the care that's given to those
stories um a lot of the stuff doesn't
really feel like gets the chance to
properly capitalized like one of my
biggest criticisms of Tom King and who's
doing the current run is his arc bill
towards something and then the ends kind
of like it doesn't feel as grandiose as
it should be so yeah that that's I mean
them I don't know what the different to
be honest no no it's just it's like I
don't know compared to TV Craig's
Netflix you write your first season and
it gets made but in comics
I don't know how widely spread it is but
it's odd to me that they didn't just
write this whole thing this is something
that's gonna sell its a watchman sequel
you know when this comes out in
paperback when this comes out in hard
but it's going to be huge a watchman
thing that people in waterstones can buy
you know get it yeah yeah it's weird and
but just don't know don't know what
we're saying it has a negative always
finding anyway a slag them off oh thinks
you can release to a month now does he
yeah who does he think he is
I mean if it's fine if he wants to do
that and you know I should say huge
thanks to the people to get in touch
with the show as well via email watching
The Watchmen pod at gmail calm we got
some great emails the first ones from
Ian Kim he
says so while looking for people sports
on Doomsday Clock - I found your podcast
on the comic books subreddit and it's
pretty [ __ ] good so far dude I think
you'll be growing into something big as
time goes by one thing to know is how
refreshing is to listen to an
intelligent discussion on the Doomsday
Clock issues and even recently about
Killing Joke review for example I tuned
in to your doomsday to review and I
expect it to be your obnoxious from now
generic YouTube reviewer who reviews the
story of explaining synopsis and nothing
more and nothing less the usual one mil
subscriber type of YouTube but nope you
guys completely went in-depth panel
white panel and gave every little kids a
piece of info you have your podcast is
some [ __ ] awesome stuff man I just
wanted to send a congratulatory email
and hope you guys become bigger as you
go on keep up the good [ __ ] dudes
I mean shower in ya be sure you didn't
write that you know come it's amazingly
fawning thank you in yeah I like how he
says we don't have 1 million subscribers
just rubbing it in yeah yes so funny
yeah honestly really really appreciate
emails like that and doesn't make it
worth it
yeah um yeah so it's brilliant yeah he
says in the second email as well don't
read the whole thing
we are pretty obnoxious though Tom
especially me to be fair I've had
comments on it in the past on other
videos on Batman countdowns yeah you
know one of the things that he says I
like Ian in the second email the one
thing that takes so well was how you two
do not give a rat's ass about Geoff
Johns yeah you genuinely like him as a
writer like I think he is really good
it's just this project might either be
too close to me or he might be [ __ ] I
really can't tell and whether it is just
my opinion or he's went bad but yeah I
did I do like the guy but I'm never
getting a job at DC I'm all Marvel now
anyway Tom I yes and loads and loads and
loads of Marvel Comics recently mm-hmm
but yeah [ __ ] the loads
I actually aren't you turn the other way
I remember when I was younger I was like
marble [ __ ] Dee seeds blonde whatever
but when I said actually reading stuff I
found I prefer DC I think it's more of a
writer's medium yeah definitely MDC as a
whole
better for graphic novels and like you
can just list off the amount of classic
graphic novels that Daniel done exactly
that brings to mind and not just because
you do now for Berkeley and but yeah
they've had absolutely classics and I
did kind of struggle when I was starting
off like with comics to really think
what Marvel had done mmm in terms of
classics I mean you've got the death of
Gwen Stacy and you've got a couple of
x-men books that are really highly
regarded Civil War obviously and but
there's not ones that really have the
esteem that something like a watchman or
a Dark Knight Returns or a Killing Joke
does there's not things that are
regarded that highly they're not winning
like Time magazine awards The Secret
Wars no it's not yeah yeah yeah it's not
going that's a secret so no one knows
about no no no yeah The Ultimates that
dated series like you know yeah some of
it I don't think has done so well David
gets in touch as well via email says
great episode guys I believe that
Ellison referenced Killing Joke I
believe the method of inserting one
colored object into a black and white
film goes at least as far back as 1925
in battleship potemkin
when the revolting Imperial Russian
sailors succeeding and taking command of
the ship they raised a red flag and
every frame of it was hand painted red
to make it stand out their ego didn't
even know that sincerely David thank you
David
for getting in touch and yeah I mean you
know we did do Killing Joke by Alan
Moore I probably want to do more Alan
Moore on the show actually our I always
say how do you like it you know yeah I
got this book from the library that
people might be aware of Alan Moore
storyteller to giant hardcover book it's
like a sort of coffee table history of
the guy you know so many photos and
frames of the comic I'm just looking for
it now and it's mind-blowing like when
you go through it you go everywhere from
the early Doctor Who future shocks weird
stuff he was doing in the North Hampton
arts lab - like from hell - like
Watchmen - like me from and debt like
Swamp Thing Lost Girls Thom strong like
the guy has had so many good series yeah
definitely and many I think he's quite a
piques your interest quite a lot because
he's not a sellout hmm and he's had so
many of his works adapted for cinema and
video games animated movies and the guy
never seems like he just doesn't seem to
like them and there's always that
intrigue to it I think it was always
quite nice recently I did a shining
podcast hmm and it's kind of nice to
discuss how the adaptation differs from
the original work and in the same way
that Stephen King hated the The Shining
it's the same way that Alan will hate
everything especially if it's got his
name on it and shout bent legs as well
yeah and that podcast awesome guy a
final email from Erik who is genuine
greatest friend of the show he says nice
Killing Joke podcast Thank You Erik glad
you mention Camelot 3000 which was of
course I believe Brian Bolland who drew
that beforehand and it was like a sort
of early prototype you know huge deal in
long narrative it was about like the
Knights of Camelot going into the future
which is just you know irresistible and
he talks about how it was really
groundbreaking at DC started introducing
gay characters in the 80s the Legion of
super-heroes soon after began hinting
about shrinking violet and lightening
lassies relationship yeah didn't know
that but I'm sure more knew that and you
know obviously did a lot of people are
aware that keep with the good work thank
you Eric and we get to issue free there
and I'd be like personal circumstances
aside just as an as a narrative you know
you read the first two you're
anticipating this highly well you was
you dug in no I was pushed back a week
this episode yeah I really did you know
I'm always an episode for kind of guy
I'm always like I sewed fors when it
gets good I think that's why George
Lucas probably started episode four and
but yeah so I'm kind of holding off
where all the pieces are in place and
then you start to see the bigger picture
whereas introductory chapters always
kind of stumble for me
and but yeah episode three you know it's
sort of building up so thing and who I'm
interested to see how they handle this
yeah you
and yeah and I was you know it I laughed
a bit actually when I saw the title of
it and called not victory nor defeat
yeah and that title kind of sums up how
I feel about the rule itself it's it's
not amazing it's not terrible it's just
in the middle yeah yeah and the cover
the smashed bottle of gin which isn't
quite a lyrical or n ISM enigmatic but
obviously you know we got a compared to
Watchmen but those covers are
unbelievable I'm thinking specifically
of the Jon Osterman folk or Mars I think
he's one of my beautiful covers of
all-time incredible but this one of just
a smash game but I like it I think it's
the best cover so far I'll be honest
yeah fight V shown on it and not only
does it symbolize that fights everywhere
the fact that it's getting smashed also
kind of symbolizes that you know
Ozymandias is against the ropes and
which is how we left them last lasted
episode issue whatever so yet I thought
it was a nice picture and the purple as
well you know it's just it's a nice
Watchmen color and you know the victory
Jin is getting smashed victory it ain't
on the cards in this episode yeah and
even the backdrop just the shadow of the
splash on this cracked concrete and yeah
the attention is excellent yeah the
style for me I don't know personally for
me it seems a little too varnished in
place by the let's talk about the other
cover which I saw someone on reddit said
this is one of the most explosive images
in the history of DC and he is right
Batman
reading Walter Kovacs his journal mm-hmm
that's a great image definitely could be
like a poster or something it to me it's
the most iconic image thus far from the
The Watchmen yeah redo mmm definitely is
even like we've not had like a Superman
iconic issue it's
it's good to see that Batman and
Rorschach are finally colliding in the
same universe and you know it's
interesting and where this is why don't
know why sooner by Candlelight know the
labs are [ __ ] billionaire hey yeah
yeah it's for the coffee effect i what
we reflect on his costume as well he's
gloves
you know he's cow your is he a big
Batman fan death you know very well has
its rank for you in terms of his
costumes yeah it's quite good
yeah dude like I've always prefer the
short areas on the cowl and this is very
sort of Dark Knight Returns II and you
can tell it's a younger guy in the suit
but airy I really do like the suit it's
really nice yeah yeah yeah it is just
kind of I don't know it's not got the
sort of you know Kapoor loo sort of
pencil shred to it yeah clean it's very
grounded looking yeah yeah it looks like
you could actually get that for
Halloween and as all the comics begin as
more began as John's begins you know the
cover is the first image in some format
or the other and you know we begin on
that and this is the thing like a lot of
people already and if you listen is in
the future it hasn't came out yet the
Han Solo film which seemingly is gonna
surrender sit yeah seemingly you know
let's not talk about the directorial
changes which are mad and Kathleen
Kennedy I don't know the [ __ ] going on
there but just honest sort of like you
know they're explaining everything in
this one movie you know they're tossing
a homer for like some things you don't
need to see something's you don't need
to know about like you know the entire
Star Wars prequels yeah
this scene of Oz Newman dies and
comedian is a Star Wars prequels of
Doomsday Clock like it's just it's fine
in a bit selfish so shows you what
happens in some sort of physical way but
none of its that stirring because you
know it's the aftermath it's it's the
shocks that the death of the comedian
causes that is the story I'm gonna
disagree with the Tom I thought this
opening was really really good I think
the art better than the original mmm and
I like that it's set up the fight it's
clear that can
Gideon's like getting his ass handed to
him here and you know going into the
next fight that awesome and Isis the one
who's on the backburner and I think you
know it does repeat them throughout the
their fight the way this one goes as
human dies throws himself out of the
window so he's able to control it much
in the same way that the comedian gets
thrown out the window so it's a nice
little twist on it as human dies is
always someone who's in control of the
situation
99% at the time unless bloody big blue
dicks in the room you know what I mean
he's he's in control so up to me it was
a nice start and like I say I do
actually prefer the the art of this to
the original your bloody you're crossing
me off your Christmas card list by now
on you he said Doomsday Clock was better
than Watchmen it's quite heresy in some
people's always maybe to say that but I
don't understand how the comedian
doesn't hit the floor and he gets
transported yes okay surely there was a
body well I was trying to kind of
remember whether we actually do see
comedians body on the street or not yeah
we you see blood being washed away yeah
exactly also I meant you know it does
make sense
continuity wise bum it doesn't make
sense at all when you think about it for
more than two seconds no I'm at the most
someone would have found his body and be
like hey we get buried you know that is
a glass it's like clearly something was
there you know in in the sort of
Watchmen story which apparently is the
real world that was we have to believe
we at the moment on watching dark on
Netflix this or German really go find
really good you think I think it's
terrible well I think it's like a good
stranger things oh no I think it's just
it's really really disagree in this yeah
we are yeah very gimmicky and there's no
character interaction in it at all but
yeah but anyway that is time-based and
yeah it's kind of it why is it
suggesting here is some sort of lost
time is the true time line comedians def
and what we're seeing now subsequently
his resurrection is some sort of
contradict I know it's not clear
and I don't think it ever will I don't
know if he can satisfy only be explained
because I don't really care
I think the comedian was dope in
Watchmen but like this resurrected dead
puppet form
I think his dialogue is flat when he
meets Ozzy I think it's not comedian
it's geoff johns move
you know eyepatch yeah it's I think it's
fine to be honest it's a good way to
include the character in the story it
won't get explained it's just one of
those things like like the x-men movies
when yeah I don't know there's loads of
stuff that's happened in the x-men movie
so they've just not explained ever they
went Professor X come back to life yeah
and even though he got killed in the
third one for an hour you're a professor
yeah how you doing so how he talked
storm anyway there are you all right
what I didn't see in the last movie
where we are you know just getting back
and so it's gonna be one of them where
they don't explain that it's just accept
it yeah you stupid comic book reader and
give us your money
what's got Watchmen on the cover he
wakes up outside this metropolis you
know you almost rounds okay you get
tales the black freighter vine people
deceive me yeah really didn't really did
especially with the sea coming in as
well it's black
mm-hm so maybe that's like a metaphor
for her in the same way that the guy
from the black freighter stumbles back
on the shore and he's mad and you know
he's not sure of his view of the world
maybe the comedian's stumbling back on
this Shore you know it looks similar to
his world but there's there's
differences and that's what's gonna make
him a killer
Geoff Johns is a genius dr. Manhattan is
yes he's in the building he's in the
frame you know yeah
hello Blake you know he says without
patience of his and wait I think the
artwork is fantastic and you know I
think he's sort of sea dog comedian here
waking up in a different time zone like
you know it's quite effective does it
have to be the button and everything
deaf is that a very important thing in
this story yeah I don't know
I think dr. Manhattan drops it for him
so maybe showing that he went back and
got his button so I don't worry don't
know sure
it only explained then why would dr.
Manhattan save comedians life at this
point
Shirley's easy care about life I don't
really
so marionette makes him care about life
because she has that baby because he was
his mate wasn't he they used to like to
go with em bars together and PN not with
the Lud all had a drink before world war
shuttle women carrying our unborn son
yeah boys will be boys just let the
ladder be I've got a lot of stuff got a
lot respect um the next page page 5 the
top where we see the fight wordlessly
yeah and like penguins are like toys in
the frame it's kind of hard to explain
they don't really have a humanities kind
of fuzz doubt behind glass but I love it
III really yeah it's great it's nice how
it's just silent and you can see like
they're the kicks in the punches and
this would be great as a like a movie
and it just has a very cinematic feel to
it you you what looking at the fight
from afar and then just as you're
getting close enough the glass smashes
and that's when the dialogue comes into
play and I can just imagine that being
in a film just starting off a movie and
as soon as the the glass cracks that's
when all the sound kind of envelops the
audience but yeah II like it mm-hmm
and comedian said strong glass Shane
would have been poetic which is fine but
to be honest with you death was a bit on
the nose I think I think Alan Moore
would have left that page blank and just
yeah are you looking at a crack in a
glass is enough like you know that's
absolutely enough it's across its face
and devote you know blah blah blah we've
got the smiley face in the background
like you know it's just staged so well
but I think yeah him just saying that
it's just all a bit and then comedian
just
bleeding the point dry like always a
comedian is quite pissy he wasn't like
he was annoyed this he knew had to land
jokes I think yeah he was always making
jokes even when they were talking about
like new killewarren yeah yeah yeah when
he was raping that woman like you know
yeah you know just doing doing it
everyone killing themselves laughing
what's he up to now
and Ozymandias okay see you face to face
a comedian I know you killed this guy in
some alternate future but whatever you
know he's quite deadly turn off the
lights I guess it works yeah I don't
know why the lights is like a big light
bulb on the control panel it's like that
thing in the sick like all those sixties
movies when it would when the hero would
like run over to the control panel and
be like a big button that said power hmm
and he would like turn that off but I
don't know now yeah it's just it is a
nice fight though yeah it's a long fight
and it's a padded fight I think and I
think we've already had padding in the
comic I think the intro as cool as it is
I don't think four would supply in any
real way and I think it just kind of you
know I'm still waiting for things to
happen to these characters compellingly
I think the Peace of being assemble is
the further issue blah blah blah but I
just from danger because these are
slightly missing they have this shoe out
on the glass this indestructible plot
device glass this should have got some
in his in his apartment yeah in a very
short story yeah yeah this double-glazed
tale you know you've got to have people
bleeding from around the eye area
because it's Watchmen so you know we see
Ozzie you know wounded on his brow it
bleeds and he just kind of flips up out
of there right yeah which I think's nice
because it mirrors the comedian doing it
yeah it's just it's nice but it's not
yeah I don't know what the point of
fight was the thing about Watchmen
originally was there's I don't think
there's any real fighting in it know
that I mean it starts off with a fight
but
there's nothing there's no other battle
that really springs to mind that I can
think of maybe towards the end when the
group take on Ozymandias up Rorschach in
the row house building I guess with the
police as well yeah but there's not
major fights in it whereas this seems
kind of beside to the point I don't
think these two characters would
immediately start fighting and if they
met one another
I think comedian kind of hold a gun at
him and sort of talk to him but yeah you
don't you don't call do you instead he
just shows up and shoots Lex Luthor yeah
yeah it's not as funny as it used to be
a comedian used to be a lot funnier than
this yeah yeah yeah you see and he's
just this thing that just the scene
replays or the scene happens for action
as you say there should have been some
sort of dialogue between the two of them
but yeah we get was he sort of you know
the superhero I guess not a superhero
but he's of a peak human isn't he you
know fleeing off the roof doing
somersaults etc but what he lands on you
know isn't enough to carry his weight he
snaps he falls you know for a hotel
canopy with his cat who I think he stole
the intrinsic field off with a cat still
alive and yeah it's a kind of its page
nine and not much has gone down really
we've had some interactions here but
still the big interactions were waiting
for we'd get to one of them here though
death yeah your main man Bruce human
Rorschach the first kind a proper see
between these guys yeah it's nice I did
really enjoy this to be honest I like
how Rorschach so just talking about
eating breakfast and he's saying he
could be killed or collect just it's
nice the way they've got broken language
and it sort of shows the fractured
psyche of Rorschach and just the the
iconography of it's really nice mmm you
know the talk about the fork he goes to
put his hand in his pocket he says oh no
that's a fork wrong pocket and yeah pull
still it's just a nice little comedic
thing yeah yeah that's face right yeah
Batman sort of puzzled that yeah but
it's sort of accepting as
well he doesn't know how this guy
managed to get anything back hey I don't
know how the guy managed to get in the
back cave you just sort of stumbled in
but here knee knee worries we'll
overlook that how were a new experience
of reading Batman comics you know you've
read a lot about my comics how
impregnable of a fortress is the Batcave
look really impregnable yeah like even
the river up to it is like laced with
mines and swells and she might be out
there
death mine River Joker huh swim up there
once and yeah it's just yeah you
wouldn't get in it's all like
voice-activated in fake stairways and
you've gotta like know the password and
you can't you can't even walk in if
you're the postman you know I mean that
like Bruce's Bruce's down in these order
and candles are farmers on prime because
it keeps using them to read books and
yeah and they're not even the postman's
getting in and he knows him on
first-name basis yeah it's that's how
impregnable it is given the journal the
COBOL though Robin in Batman Forever did
like cartwheel into it I went so yeah
you just never know maybe fee yeah yeah
so yeah he gets given the journal would
you kind of established through the
early image which is you know a huge
Roman you know genuinely regardless of
what stories and it's really cool to see
we're in Killing Joke territory which we
just visited on yellow checkout which
was lucky it seems like every time we do
Simek in the show it pops up later down
the line you know I probably wouldn't
have recognized all this if we hadn't
just done Killing Joke
no no and like it's kind of like oh it's
Killing Joke from them from the
background you can sort of recognize it
anyway but Killing Joke in the sense of
the clown in the glass cabinet that you
know pictures heavily with in the air
and more original so you know it does
have direct references there and we're
with two characters with two new
characters if you free now have they
grown on you they know but they do in
this issue
they do I know you hated them because
you can
we would talk about this before the show
but yeah by now I was either alright
just let them be um they saw this
chapter itself sort of sums up like
modern comic book audiences they're all
idiots they're stumbling through these
pictures of like famous things from
comics yeah yeah it's not massively
impacting them but it's just you know
that enjoying being there so that's
probably why doomsday clocks getting
like 10 out of 10 and stuff yeah even
though Jeff Jones clearly wrote this
section saying that all comic book
readers who've been reading comics for
less than two years are complete morons
and all comic book listeners who listen
to this show
you've been reading comics for less than
two years are also complete morons what
you weren't there at the comic book
store the day that they're released
Watchmen issue one you're pathetic we
get Batman again here with Rorschach in
a fun panel if purely in terms of
composition so there's slapstick blacked
it's not annoying panel grid which we
love to see here this is page 12 the
first six panels Batman is pretty much
exclusively in one stance
you know expressions changing minor
behind him Rorschach is equally Reggie
behaving that way and you know then
there is some direct kind of as you say
slapstick interaction you know what page
you on for that's all it's been a long
day which is kind of you know an odd
confession from master Wayne ya know
it's it's nice it's quite funny it's
it's good that they're like subverting
the two darkest characters of the
universes and they're like this little
joke thing they're finally found each
other when they're gonna go on stage Tom
the [ __ ] team up with a joker they'd
have a bangin show that we get don't be
good some sort of Roy yet would work and
yeah they sort of that's it really does
not too much revelation say we have some
more
ding-ding juxtapositions him looking at
his hand and then you know we're
learning more about I mean super world's
the public always pretty much hates the
superhero so it's a given here you know
everyone's tense local law enforcement
and we get this element that okay here's
why I hate modern comics hey events I
hate of laborious Li laid out stories of
kind of things that aren't quite
explained that becomes huge later on ie
this old man his grandson using Justice
League of America this guy is something
like that mr. Fonda yeah so mr. Thunder
rebirth the issue one I told here read
Tom Lee together and is slugging it off
that you don't understand this and so
mr. Thunder was featured in that he's
basically in a nursing home and he said
something I have got the notes down here
he said he needed to find the Justice
Society and that he was sorry for what
he'd done right him that was that was
pretty much d there the summary of his
his appearance in rebirth yeah so I
don't know what its gonna tie into this
but yeah it's nice to know that the guys
were regretful and it's clearly is it
looks very depressed mm-hmm in this
issue
the Superman theory you know the
metahumans all these grab words for this
world that John's is kind a half
building like I don't know it's just all
quite saying me personally but it
swelling there the problem when things
are done in the act like the the central
universe is you can't set something in
stone because someone down the line
might want to change it or they might
dig themselves into a hole that
completely ruins I'd the continuity and
they've got to go back and redo it all
and it's it's very clear that John's is
sort of dipping his toe here he's not
going all out with it he's hop he's
pulling his punches you know I mean
where is in something like injustice
which is an absolutely brilliant comic
they're given free rein over what they
do
with all of the characters and it makes
it a lot more interesting
whereas this being in the main universe
that kind of got hold back because you
never know what they're gonna do that
could [ __ ] everything up Tom mm-hmm-hmm
you could have another Barbara Gordon in
a wheelchair on your hands you know what
I mean
still some of the deadliest puns ever
when Joker's schutzler know you know
yeah book puns man I've really stopped
we have to reviewed that I've always
fought about that shower Alamo obviously
I'm always Shannon Alan Moore I'm
currently reading the Bo Jeffrey saga
which is kind of his coronation Street
impression from the 80s
yeah with Steve Park house so definitely
shall the morning right well we're gonna
try and get Alan Moore on the show at
some point one day but I'm kind of
worried if we do get if he listens to
any of this you'll think no [ __ ] that
loud sounds like a psychopath and that
other one
Tom sounds even bigger of a psychopath
right right well you're talking of
psychopathic moves I know you know I
found a black freighter I understand
that I'm not a huge fan myself I'm since
I update in it Oh already a German okay
you could have written something good
but no you wrote this kind of stay or
uninteresting like there's no spin here
there's no it's not worried shits kind
of boorish yeah and it's really like I
don't like the black freighter so it
would be the first thing I would cut
from the comic and and I don't know why
I do a lot of people like the black
freighter and always said Eric said that
it took him 35 years but eventually he
did like it
do people in general like it because
it's not something I would rehash no no
he got made as a movie extra yeah on the
DVD so maybe there was some sort of
American policies part of book you know
it's always yeah
Gator Asian but yeah we have the German
here yeah and they're sort of rehashing
things
yeah because they've got Rex Mason Kirk
Langstrom and Lady Clayface right and
who uses Silver Age villain and very old
comic book character so it is it's good
to see her return even if it's
it's a very minor um yeah and it's nice
that they're the tie in this Silver Age
thing into this old television program
but I'm more interested in the news that
was going on and so we did just kind of
dance all this but it does actually
explain what the Superman theory is and
which is asking why 97 percent of the
world
superheroes are American and I think
that's pointing towards dr. Manhattan
creating superheroes right um you know
the do blame the US government
experimenting on people but it's
probably dr. Manhattan but all that's
derailed in favor of this black and
white TV show murder mystery thing yeah
that is it doesn't really tell an
engaging story and and just I don't know
towels and blood favor allowed more to
stretch your muscle that he was already
quite good at you know these sort of
faux horror narratives and you know he
sees he's brilliant at that
good to see Alfred actually bought the
ring in this next sequence yeah he loves
to bottle that lad he's getting tea he's
washing the clothes yeah he's you know
he's in a nice wage he's due he does 120
hours a week this lad am so yeah it's
good to say that he's always on the ball
yeah yeah and you know Reggie takes up
his mask and we seen for the first time
yeah what did you think so I was like
who that focus up yeah who is it
I read oh no no kind of yeah we do kind
of get a flashback for him where he sees
the alien and warp into Manhattan so
it's obvious that he was there but I
have no idea like from his perspective
he was driving a car and then it just
appeared out of nowhere
hmm I don't know well you know maybe he
doesn't need it be anyone special sure
it's like Rey's parents isn't it yeah
yeah I'm sick of everyone being the
chosen one
yes but they did kind of tease this out
for three issues and it was no one yeah
yeah and they can't really answer is
being someone really
I don't really see how that's gonna be
read and it's the first time that a
black person's taken something off a
white guy normally it's white people
stealing all the stuff from black people
mm-hmm so yeah but to me it just seems
like a very shallow way to get black
character into the story like I won a
video that I've just done Tom I'm gonna
promote my own [ __ ] right now so
basically Idris Elba said that James
Bond this should do something different
this should make it a woman others
should make it a black guy and and I
don't think that's right not because I'm
a massive racist Tom mm-hmm
I just think that black people and women
they're they deserve their own iconic
characters and it kind of devalues it
for me when someone just if they do a
gender swap or a race swap I'd much
rather see an iconic character create it
that was black or female because then
you can't kind of negatively take away
anything from it you can't be like oh
well it used to be a white guy
you know I mean black Black Panthers
coming out next month I'm so hyped for
it I think it's gonna be absolutely
amazing and it's completely almost
completely a black cast and it's got so
much going for it that will be Jordan
man what a legend exactly like imagine
if they'd already be in a white panther
movie and Where's Wally would yeah would
cheap it would cheapen it you know what
I mean it would kind of be like oh well
black people can only do stuff if a
white person opens the door for them you
know I mean like same a Wonder Woman if
Wonder Woman had have been a man I don't
I don't know well you can't get
operations these days anyway it all
those female activists feminists and
that who went crazy for the movie would
they have as much pride in it because
you know I mean and it's just kind of I
don't know it just seems very a very
cheap way to I'd much rather they block
brought a new black character in that
was just completely original instead of
being like all this guy used to be white
but would
do some edgy will try and make them
black I mean I don't know how black
people feel about it to be honest they
might be over the moon seeing a black
Rorschach in but I would just rather the
new character was created no not being
like oh you're ruining my favorite white
characters I just think that they
deserve their own characters and that's
why you know I'm really excited for
Black Panther I think it's gonna really
really do something amazing and not just
film wise like for the industry as a
whole I think it's going to show that
black superheroes deserve their place
whereas Jones is just like no I'll just
make it just change the color of your
skin just do Rorschach again but making
black rule black as we said before yeah
racist he yeah as he Sprague's his head
something quite gruesome and quite
symbolic happens where he's bleeding
heavily it's pouring down his face like
a pall we've seen many times before you
know echoed throughout these books and
yes he's doing that he's pointing out
with differences he's feeling being in
this mansion from where he grew up
you know that's sort of division we go
in and out we learn a little bit more
but you know the adjournment but again
it's some sort of chess game sort of
dichotomy between good and evil spilled
out in sort of I don't know I think it
more had his hands on this a little bit
a bit more intriguing yeah it feels more
disjointed as well whereas Moya was
interweaving the two storylines together
perfectly as one whereas this just seems
kind of to be honest Tom I've got
absolutely no idea what happens in a
second because I just don't remember out
no no me neither
I just don't remember it Tom I don't
just went over my head and one of the
worst things about it it's not
interesting and then you have the old
couple arguing about it as well and it's
kinda like not care about seeing this
it's gonna spend more time on this than
they did explain and how the comedian
got to you know I mean Tom and I like
that you know in a in a club here we see
Stuart Lee who I don't know if I'm
reading too far into this but I know
this to attain a lot more friends I know
that many more has been interviewed by
Stuart Lee yeah unlike a person it's
like a live show someone less on YouTube
is really cool
is him getting here hair more yeah if it
is yeah I didn't know that it was I
didn't know who she really was but yeah
that's how I would take it yeah because
it's in the same way that the bottle got
smashed at the start it's very similar
the way that the bottle gets smashed off
his head
mm-hmm so yeah it's probably like oh
[ __ ] years is hate yeah I mean next
issue they'll probably be two podcasters
getting shot with an invisible gun
that's what I think about years we
learned this is Joker's turf yeah he
wouldn't want from these two you know
the kind of maker that they wearing the
boss doesn't like it you know we learned
that this is his crew fight kicks off
and we learn that they have invisible
weapons
I loved it Tom I'm not gonna lie I
[ __ ] loved it I thought that's
hilarious
yeah it's just brilliant because we were
the first episode were like all right
why is everyone like scared of the mime
he's just pointing his finger at people
and stuff I mean just to see him point
his finger and then it blows the back of
that guy's head off yeah
liked it liked it Tom and then you see
it from the angle it's a bit like the
Indiana Jones The Last Crusade when he's
walking or with that invisible bridge
and then the government hands a bit to
another ankle you can just see the light
catch it right yes it's a nice reveal
yeah Jehovah and the panelling is good
her face is good as well stone looking
forward resolute and you know it's a
bloody comic yeah it's it's not gruesome
but it does have its violence you know
it has another big fight
similar to Ozzy's tumble you need to
have these motions in the comic and yeah
but get to see the gun more and more as
the scenes play out you can kind of make
out where they are I do really like this
sequence where she pulls out the knife
or I guess the sort of the rope or
whatever she has and she goes she closed
about where isn't it like a wire thing
and
no you see the hand you see the face
being cut open like you know yeah the
art is pretty cool though she she cuts
the gun in half the barrel you know the
hand it's a barrage her going for the
eyes you've got pretty eyes
well she looks at you with those eyes
and the the you know the rope tearing
across it's really effective isn't it
yeah and I really this really wouldn't
be rounded the characters um I was
thinking year they'd they've done it
these guys you know the good yeah is it
they want to go find the Joker so it's
nice that the you know the three groups
are kind of coming together of as human
dies and Lex Luthor Batman and Rorschach
and now my man marionette and the Joker
and Harley Quinn it's nice that they're
sort of naturally gravitating to to one
another I just hope I just hope the mind
doesn't put that gun some down somewhere
and forget about it air tub right I'm a
quite a big fan of the the markings that
calls the supposed to blindness here
turning into the plane on the bottle of
whiskey yeah it's nice yeah it's just
good um John Susie he's winning his
round at this point like I really did
like the issue I'm not gonna spoil how I
felt at the end cuz the last [ __ ] page
ruined everything but yeah and join it
and all the characters kind of get in
their moment and it's not they work
better as separate groups yeah I didn't
like when they were all huddled together
and Archie
going off and doing their own thing
they're allowed to expand on their own
dynamics and it works a lot better
mm-hmm and I mean Lindbergh whiskey of
course you think of the Lindbergh baby
kidnapping you know in 1932 which was
kind of what the famous is looking at
one of the richest men in the US I
believe so it's kinda interesting I was
there looking for their child as well so
it's a little bit on the nose again but
a little bit more soul as well yeah they
very nice Thomas Tom if I didn't what I
did that he'd before his own words
you're on the limbo but
you're right you're right it is yeah
it's a nice room we pull out we have the
Power Rangers
you know reveal all the corpses strewn
amongst them which is fine we have our
Rangers episode did that happen
Zordon was involved but yeah you know
these huge events yet again not only
they have these ancillary characters
that become important later on they have
news reports which I guess more had as
well to a certain extent but they you
know they are very useful there are
these parallels being drawn with the
world we're seeing right now these
detectors in airports this strict
immigration you know meta-gene detectors
on their own populace all these
different things that we're finding out
about we get a lot of information here
we see the old couple arguing over the
remote for the German played against the
grandad looking in the window it could
work better I see what it's trying to do
but I don't think any of the images stir
me as such yeah and I don't know if it's
just the way it's being drawn that they
don't connect as well that as they could
do like Gibbons would have matched these
images up a lot better I feel and but
yeah I'm still getting the message I
mean yeah I don't feel like this feels
like fan fiction anymore I do feel like
it feels like a proper sequel um but
yeah just slight missteps but nothing is
angering me and we get to see the the
squid attack from a different angle here
yeah I guess Reggie's memory is a taxi
driver so again it's like the only
texture we really know is the lesbian I
think you know she's one of the only
ones actually played out to a certain
character level so yeah he learns about
this and then we see a very flaky Bruce
staring aim yeah I like the little
Bubastis sure it's completely skipped my
air freshener yeah yeah and there beyond
the steering wheel shown that bicycle
again is you know he's in everything but
yeah this cut the eventual thing that
comes from this situation really annoyed
me and but yes it's cool to just see
Batman very
straight to the point he's like it's
okay you're safe you slept for almost 24
hours I read your book yeah yeah and
when he says I know where dr. yeah oh
[ __ ] it's gonna kick off yeah yeah yeah
that was the kind of false lead there
and a bit disappointing for his benefit
he found temporal anomalies in our
comments like well of course you know
yeah he we see the German as well paint
playing on the little TV when he passes
by and it we get a cool bit of Batman
Batman stuff like you know when he hops
on the back of the van and he's
silhouette struck and human this
Rorschach teaming up but definitely not
a fan of how this issue concludes well I
laughed at the little gun thing the
grappling hook then Batman pulls out and
then Rorschach pulls her so and kind of
hmm yeah you know it's a bit of a dick
joke in it yeah um yeah so I was on
board at this point but then when Batman
he leads him in in this cell in Arkham
and then he closes the door and I'm he
say this is where you belong ha ha
gotcha gotcha gotcha which is yes
completely stupid Batman wouldn't do
that all um I don't know why like first
off he'd be [ __ ] fuming you because
the guy knows where the Batcave is that
he's late the lace that were mines to
protect it you know what I mean he's not
letting this guy go to an insane asylum
I can blab to all the Batman's villains
in the next cell like oh yeah the
Batcave it's in Bruce it's in Wayne
Manor he's not doing that and he doesn't
bat man doesn't just dump people in
Arkham then walk out like he literally
just dumps him he's like it's your
problem now warden um yeah and it's just
the urgencies gone like when they said I
know where dr. Manhattan is I was it oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and it just
completely derailed that before for the
sake of it but why did Batman have
Rorschach asleep in his house for 24
hours and not do it then
yeah why is he waited to wake him up
sneak him in somewhere you know the lads
on the clock he's that mr. freeze could
be you know killing mr. frosty like ice
cream van man you know I mean instead
he's playing this little game with
Rorschach to lead him into a cell it
doesn't make any sense and it's just in
general one of my biggest problems with
comics is that every issue has to end on
a cliffhanger no matter how little sense
it makes and how true to the character
is they always have to end it like oh
wow how they can you know it harkens
back to the 1966 Batman show when they
used to end it every episode where
they'd be in a death trap and be like
tune in next time viewers yeah it's just
stupid and you know this this isn't
gonna hold anyway in the comic of law
it's gonna be out in ten minutes I mean
we all know arguments eylem has a
revolving door policy anyway so he's not
staying in there for long no it's just
and it just ruins the buildup in the
relationship that the two were building
yeah the two had really good chemistry
together
it just completely ruins it Tom and it
doesn't make any sense and it's it's not
what Batman would do no he just it just
I'm annoyed tom is this kind of a sort
of metaphor for how DC characters will
treat all the Watchmen characters or
maybe that you guys suck we should have
never brought you back and we get of
course a quote at the end because it's
you know it's a watchman parody to a son
exam far better is it to dare mighty
things to win glorious triumphs even
though checkered by failure than to rank
with those poor spirits who neither
enjoy nor suffer much because they live
in a gray Twilight the nose not victory
nor defeat
Theodore Roosevelt yeah does that stir
you I don't know I don't know why means
into like the story no and there is this
addendum as there always is
which is always kind of its basic up
piece of text it's a Hollywood tabloid
story about the murder of Carver Coleman
and his life in sidebar notes we learn
about the birth of Rhea far a conspiracy
in the death of Sergeant Rock and
reference to John law and Libby Lawrence
who are Justice Society members
tarantula and Liberty Bell so nothing
really that impinges on the plot that
we've read so far but you know more sort
of background I again I think all the
watchman background stuff sucking baby
damn dry bugs all moats I probably the
most barren in the whole book but pretty
much all of them I think are really cool
especially under the hood stuff I love
and like you know there's some excellent
writing there but I mean all in all defi
you enjoyed Daisy free right yeah sort
of it's just the ending was like so bad
that it just completely took me out of
the book and once again I was really
getting on board with a story and just
to have that ending completely derail it
because I know exactly how it's gonna
play out but Atlanta's gonna realize he
made a mistake when something bad
happens like dr. Manhattan returns or
something and he's gotta go back to
Arkham to get him out but someone's
already went back and got some [ __ ] yeah
and it's just dragging it out and it's
it's not intelligent it's not an
intelligent we move on Batman's behalf
he would never play it like that and
well you know all of his characters he
trapped with respect and he didn't make
them idiots you know there weren't like
horror movie characters that split up
you know I mean they weren't doing dumb
things just yeah yeah
just yeah just trimmed it for me a bit
yeah yeah about you Tom yeah I'm really
talked about what you thought was ending
the ending yeah I totally grew of you in
the sense that it's gonna be reversible
that it feels very much a sort of you
know a TV ending that doesn't really
mean anything cos you know these plots
are interwoven so delicately you're
right there is a relationship at stake
here a friendship burgeoning and I think
you just saw stamps on the embers before
they get chance to lie and I don't
really like it it doesn't really push
the plot forward that much you know
there's some nice drawing in it I think
like in behind the bars and you know I
think both of them fit the profile well
but yeah all in all
nothing too striking for me in general
I'm not really a fan of this stuff and I
think the problem is because I'm just a
[ __ ] Alan Moore junkie at the moment
it's not as good as Tom strong I'm
afraid it's not as good as Toby struggle
from hell personally for me but you know
shout out to Doomsday Clock please get
in touch with us watching Watchmen pod
at gmail.com what do you think of the
show give us some feedback on episodes
we've done including this one or any the
Watchmen stuff or stuff we're gonna get
into you know future coming episodes let
us know on their death your YouTube
channel yeah it's just youtube.com slash
Definition 1988 I think or if not just
definition but may no one cares anymore
so let's be honest we're all just going
to die and there's nothing no Doomsday
Clock escoba man it could turn it round
don't want it to time I just want and I
tell you what when this goes bimonthly
[ __ ] and he'll make yeah yeah it's gonna
be just gonna suck the life Oh amazing
long and I was really not lying because
I don't really know the whole DC
universe in general but they were saying
that because this series ends a year in
time of the DC current timeline that it
being like affects a lot of other things
because you know it delays things and
plot things they want to get to ya which
it is annoying like when they do these
crossover stories because it just [ __ ]
off like the writing so much I am
reviewing a lot of new 52 and graphic
novels for my website definition of
current UK and there's a big crossover
event in the new 52 universe and
roundabout volume 5 of every graphic
novel and it just you can see like
writers just have to stop their story in
the middle of it and tie into this
crossover and it's not it's not part of
the main plot so it's not as interesting
and you just get these wash of mediocre
stories and honestly like every vol 5 in
the new 52 is crap it's like just
rubbish because they have to tie in a
fit around this main comic book
storyline it's just not very good and
I'm really hoping this doesn't do it
because it has the potential to
completely derail rebirth which has been
good to great so far so yeah okay well
as I said before please get in touch
please comment please share you know do
appreciate everyone listening to the
show and yeah get any touch of us and
enjoying us going through it makes it
all work at death even if I have to read
this but we can do this episode and you
know people can dig it as well hopefully
yeah forget about life for a while don't
they come yeah yeah exactly
a little bit and but yes for listening
guys we'll be back soon
we'll be doing Watchmen they will be
back three times a month at this rate
and then the TV show we'll come out and
I'll be doing every day then we'll do
the iPhone game and you know yeah so
we'll get to that but next up is
Watchmen that's what we're gonna cover
in next and then we need to just sort of
get cracking on that series maybe do a
few but yeah I appreciate all you guys
listening as well and we'll get those
ears def has been a pleasure as ever man
yeah it's been lovely speaking to you
it's a good night from me all right it's
a good night from Queen yes
[Music]